tellement plus jeune âge je suis tombé
amoureux de cette région parce que nous
étions vivants
nous étions heureux parmi les bruits les
vignes les gens chaleureux soit 4000
hectares du nord au sud de chalon sur
saône la côte chalonnaise regorge de
curiosités et d'histoire claude ça
laisse les raconte à des randonneurs
curieux
il leur fait découvrir les coins connus
et plus souvent méconnus et nous
embarque avec lui voyez la plaine la
base de cette pente
ça s'appelle et passe bas c'est là
qu'ils aient eu lieu la bataille de buxy
en 1461 aux normes mars mulhouse 471
entre charles le téméraire les troupes
de charles le téméraire et les troupes
du roi de france sait c'est quand même
remarquable d'une plongée dans le passé
sur les hauteurs de montagny claude
salesse nous emmène ensuite à culles les
roches à la découverte des grottes
refuge de l'homme de néandertal
cinquante mille ans avant notre ère les
premières fouilles dans cette grotte ont
eu lieu en 1865 par un imprimeur de
chalon sur saône d'abord puis dans les
années 20 par massonneau connus pour
être les fouilleurs de solutré parmi les
découvertes des silex de nombreux
ossements et un vrai émerveillement pour
nos randonneurs du jour naissait de
s'imaginer comment on a pu se réfugier
dans des endroits comme ça qu'on en
appui vivre comme ça je suis pas plein
de questions loin c'est comme une force
c'est à dire on a l'impression de
rentrer disant je dirais dans dans l'âme
de la terre parce qu'en définitive c'est
un puits et on sait pas jusqu'où il va
nous emmener cette grotte de culles les
roches est la plus importante visible
sur la falaise de l'art nous partons à
la découverte du château de pontus de
tyard poète et philosophe bourguignons
qui devint même évêque son château
renferme certains mystères le président
de l'association de sauvegarde nous le
fait découvrir
je te par 3 vous parlez de pontus de
tyard si vous êtes un peu pressé je peux
être directement les vous montrer un des
mystères du château à côté de la
bibliothèque dans un passage étroit
haut de 1 m 30 nous entrons dans le
colombier normalement fermée au public
il pouvait accueillir 700 pigeons leur
présence a longtemps été un vrai point
d'interrogation pour les historiens à 5
hypothèse qui aurait été séduisante
cette pensée que puisqu'on est près des
bibliothèques c'est la littérature sera
actuelle des pigeons voyageurs
mais non absolument pas on pense
vraiment que c'était des pigeons
destinée plutôt alimentaires
alimentation
le mystère continue dans les jardins du
château avec ses miroirs sur le mur
d'enceinte censé recréer les fenêtres du
bâtiment où ces silhouettes installé
dans le verger conservatoire
la balade touche à sa fin claude nous
emmène sous le viaduc de crin sony à 3km
l'ancienne voie ferrée relier saint
gengoux le national à montchanin à la
fin du 19e siècle démonter cent ans plus
tard elle est aujourd'hui une voie verte
[Musique]